for one thing the interaction with the
fans I mean with my readers in the old
days before the internet I would get you
know a half dozen fan letters a year
that would be delivered by the post
office you know through my publisher
they would write my publisher and my
publisher would forward a letter and I
would know that I had a fan in South
Dakota or something like that who who
liked the book and there was always a
thrill to get those of course with the
internet and the advent of email that
increased those books became more and
more successful that increased even more
and when these websites began to
proliferate there's even more but
there's a dark side of it too i mean
i've recently been embroiled in some
corals on the internet and have put
forward the view as the internet is
toxic as many as good people are on the
internet you know in the old days I'm
sure there were people out there who
hated my books but they didn't write me
you know the letters that I got those
half dozen letters were all oh you're
wonderful I read your book and this is
the greatest book I ever read and I had
where I've never written an author
before it but now I'm writing you you
know I still get those letters they get
hundreds of those letters and emails but
now thanks to the wonders of the
Internet I also get the letter saying
that I suck and my books were are trash
and you know or they used to love my
books but now they don't love my books
why they feel compelled to write and
tell me this I have I have no idea I
mean there are many writers out there
whose books I don't like but I don't
write these writers letters saying I
don't like her books but something about
the Internet has empowered all the
[ __ ] in the world to take to the
computer and and feel that the the
people that they dislike would like to
know their opinion that this is not true
so I don't I don't know the Internet is
a strange and somewhat sometimes scary
phenomena